Caption: um so we have Damien here he is a
Caption: consultant CTO architect and trainer
Caption: from Brisbane and he's here today
Caption: to tell us the most important thing you
Caption: need to know about microservices
Caption: so take it away thank you
Caption: yeah there we go thank you so much April
Caption: um this is amazing how good are
Caption: conferences
Caption: um
Caption: this is cool thank you all for coming
Caption: um so my name is Damian
Caption: um as April said I'm I'm from Brisbane
Caption: Damien M on Twitter and I'm here to talk
Caption: about the most important thing you need
Caption: to know about microservices which is
Caption: somewhat clickbaity but I will get there
Caption: um
Caption: for those who can't see well
Caption: um this photo I took on Thursday were
Caption: sitting at the docks on Frio watching
Caption: container ships come in and I thought
Caption: that's a perfect
Caption: picture for this talk so I added that
Caption: one in
Caption: um firstly
Caption: um I'd like to thank all of the sponsors
Caption: of this event um obviously without
Caption: sponsors events um can't go ahead and
Caption: also all of the the Krillin volunteers
Caption: for this conference it's been as a
Caption: speaker it's been amazing so far and I
Caption: hope you're having a really cool day
Caption: cool
Caption: start my timer all right so who am I um
Caption: I'm a consultant CTO essentially I've
Caption: been a consultant for a long time and
Caption: I've been a CTO of a few different
Caption: companies so
Caption: um a few of these you might have heard
Caption: of ratify which is now Telstra purple I
Caption: worked there for a long time
Caption: it was an early
Caption: um early person at octopus deploy I've
Caption: done a couple of very bad hardware and
Caption: software startups
Caption: that I don't talk about too much at
Caption: parties
Caption: um and and as a result of that I'm now a
Caption: freelance kind of consultancy yeah it's
Caption: what I call it so essentially I I help
Caption: I've I found a little happy spot where I
Caption: I work with smaller businesses
Caption: um and bring you know my
Caption: you can see from here in the photo I am
Caption: middle-aged white guy in Tech
Caption: um
Caption: I've got 23 years experience of seeing
Caption: the good and the bad and and I sort of
Caption: work with smaller companies to help them
Caption: avoid those sorts of problems
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: yeah that's what I do and also I'm going
Caption: to talk about this a little bit at the
Caption: end
Caption: um I'm a trainer at a company called
Caption: stack mechanics which I'll talk a little
Caption: bit about later on essentially to help
Caption: people you know in larger groups to
Caption: avoid some of these mistakes
Caption: uh ramblings is the first time back for
Caption: a while all right so the agenda today
Caption: um
Caption: I'm gonna give you a little bit of
Caption: background and historical context
Caption: um about microservices because I'm a big
Caption: believer that in understanding the
Caption: history of something you can kind of
Caption: understand what problem it's solving and
Caption: you know why we might want to do that
Caption: um I'm going to talk about some of the
Caption: mistakes that I see and the impact of
Caption: those mistakes that I've seen and then
Caption: some of the principles and techniques
Caption: and and thinking and design principles
Caption: to
Caption: um
Caption: not make those mistakes and I'm going to
Caption: get into some of the sort of tech stack
Caption: details but um essentially it's more
Caption: around conceptual stuff
Caption: so
Caption: some background
Caption: for a lot of years with with ratify
Caption: and also my solo consulting stuff we'd
Caption: often kind of go into the burning
Caption: building
Caption: rescue stuff
Caption: um and often in those situations you get
Caption: to a point where people are like we need
Caption: guarantees that this is going to work
Caption: and you know we can't guarantee anything
Caption: because everything's on fire so what we
Caption: started to do you know and and you know
Caption: these sorts of approaches over the last
Caption: 10 12 13 years
Caption: is you can't make big promises so what
Caption: we would do is ship something really
Caption: small really quickly and then ship
Caption: something else really small really
Caption: quickly to kind of get some runs on the
Caption: board and and prove things
Caption: um
Caption: and you know these patterns that we sort
Caption: of took out of that
Caption: um
Caption: eventually became you know called
Caption: microservices
Caption: lots of Tooling in the sort of
Caption: infrastructure octopus deploy and and
Caption: cerealog and some of the sort of tools
Caption: that as.net developers I'm assuming most
Caption: people here.net Developers
Caption: about half okay cool
Caption: um it's almost came out of that space
Caption: where we're just like getting in as a
Caption: consultancy and having to solve problems
Caption: really really quickly
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: that's part of the background of why I
Caption: like microservices the other part of
Caption: this talk is we are in a very hype
Caption: driven industry you would probably know
Caption: this yes
Caption: um
Caption: and it's very cyclic as well and sort of
Caption: part of my
Caption: advantage of being you know in tech for
Caption: 20 something years is you start to see
Caption: the same bad ideas recycle with new
Caption: names and you'll see a couple of nods
Caption: here you go yes and
Caption: you know sometimes those those ideas get
Caption: renamed it's like this is a great new
Caption: thing and I kind of you know put on my
Caption: grumpy old man pants I'm like no we've
Caption: done that you know
Caption: and and what happens is
Caption: everyone's kind of jumps on these
Caption: bandwagons and they write blog posts
Caption: because everyone wants to kind of get
Caption: noticed for Stuff
Caption: um and you've got blog posts like oh
Caption: this is an amazing thing and people want
Caption: to get on Hacker News and companies
Caption: wanted to attract Talent you know we'll
Caption: do posts
Caption: um about how they how they did things
Caption: um my favorite is Uber engineering's
Caption: blog because every couple of years they
Caption: change everything and write a blog post
Caption: about it
Caption: um you know one year it was like we've
Caption: moved away from postgres to mySQL
Caption: because it's faster and then two years
Caption: later they just finished that migration
Caption: go well no that was a bad idea we're
Caption: going back again
Caption: um and and that's kind of fine for Uber
Caption: because they're massive and they've got
Caption: you know billions of dollars of venture
Caption: capital funding and most of us aren't
Caption: Uber we don't we can't afford to make
Caption: those mistakes and you know rebuild our
Caption: database
Caption: um every you know two years
Caption: um so yeah part of the problem is very
Caption: high driven everyone wants to be kind of
Caption: in on the latest thing
Caption: and we end up with this
Caption: so for anyone who can't see it as well
Caption: this is a sort of well-known meme
Caption: um of a dog sitting drinking a coffee
Caption: with flames all around him I'm saying
Caption: this is fine
Caption: um and I'm going to repeat this a few
Caption: times so if you sort of can't see the
Caption: slides and you hear me say this is fine
Caption: just picture the dog in the burning
Caption: building things that everything's all
Caption: good
Caption: um so yeah we built these things and it
Caption: ends up just in in a disaster and as
Caption: much as I love I actually quite enjoy as
Caption: a consultant you know going to the
Caption: burning building and picking stuff up I
Caption: I it's a sick satisfaction I get from it
Caption: it would be great for the entire
Caption: industry if we didn't do it if we didn't
Caption: set stuff on fire in the first place
Caption: um so my goal today is sort of I
Caption: understand why we might do microservices
Caption: um and and some of the thinking we need
Caption: to do so that we can stop um setting
Caption: things on fire
Caption: all right so history
Caption: again this is one of these everything
Caption: old is new again
Caption: um
Caption: every idea in software is built on
Caption: something before it solving a problem
Caption: before it so I want to sort of talk a
Caption: little bit about
Caption: um my version of the history of
Caption: microservices and
Caption: so
Caption: again there's some assumptions and
Caption: opinions here but I have you know
Caption: cross-checked this with a few people
Caption: so it started with something called SOA
Caption: service oriented architecture if you
Caption: know ingots
Caption: who was around when Soul was a thing
Caption: yeah good number good number
Caption: um
Caption: so that was a cool idea and the idea was
Caption: that and this has been the early 2000s
Caption: um in the sort of.net space it was like
Caption: dot Net One soap was the great new thing
Caption: and web services
Caption: a few people go oh
Caption: and the idea was good it was you had
Caption: Loosely coupled services
Caption: that that autonomously managed a
Caption: business process
Caption: and you could then build applications
Caption: based on those services so you know you
Caption: might have service a and service B and
Caption: server C and service D and then
Caption: application a goes well I would like
Caption: that thing and that thing and that thing
Caption: and the applications that sit on top of
Caption: the services and big companies could
Caption: build that services and everything would
Caption: be great
Caption: it wasn't
Caption: because what we'd end up with
Caption: is something that looked a little bit
Caption: more like this where every service or
Caption: every application talks to every service
Caption: and every service talks to every other
Caption: service and they're usually all sitting
Caption: on top of a shared database
Caption: and it was just a mess and a lot of this
Caption: was because we got the modeling wrong
Caption: you know it was meant to be
Caption: an autonomous business process managed
Caption: by a service but typically it wasn't
Caption: um the modeling got wrong and it wasn't
Caption: self-contained at all it wasn't
Caption: autonomous and everything you know
Caption: looked like this and from the last I
Caption: know a few a few of you have worked on
Caption: this sort of fun
Caption: um you know I worked on one where you
Caption: had a data manager service where they
Caption: sort of re-implemented a relational
Caption: database on top of a relational database
Caption: over soap
Caption: um and it looked a lot like this and
Caption: every service needed to start in the
Caption: right order or the application would not
Caption: work so then we had a service manager
Caption: run a service or something that made
Caption: sure that things got started in the
Caption: right way
Caption: um and it was bad so the software
Caption: industry came up with a great solution
Caption: to this does anyone remember what that
Caption: was
Caption: it was the Enterprise service bus
Caption: um
Caption: which was you know vendors came in we'll
Caption: solve these problems
Caption: um and Enterprise service buses if you
Caption: don't remember they were they were
Caption: expensive
Caption: um they were generally sold on golf
Caption: courses to cios and then just put in
Caption: place
Caption: is very triggering for you I can tell
Caption: you
Caption: so and again the idea of an Enterprise
Caption: service bus wasn't a bad one so the idea
Caption: is that we had our services and rather
Caption: than them all talking to each other they
Caption: would talk to this Enterprise service
Caption: bus and the applications would talk to
Caption: the Enterprise service bus and the
Caption: Enterprise service bus would figure out
Caption: where to Route requests and how to
Caption: translate them and whatever else
Caption: and all of this
Caption: um logic was in the hands of of business
Caption: analysts and Enterprise Architects and
Caption: the idea is that the the developers
Caption: could just cut code on these Services
Caption: um
Caption: the problem was
Caption: we ended up with so much logic in this
Caption: service bus
Caption: um they became very fragile because
Caption: essentially you're doing software
Caption: development in a browser window
Caption: for this talk was a browser window that
Caption: looked a lot like SharePoint writing
Caption: code in there without validation without
Caption: testing things
Caption: um and so what happened was it became
Caption: very fragile so nobody wanted to touch
Caption: the logic in the Enterprise service bus
Caption: so as
Caption: agile developers what did we do we
Caption: routed around it
Caption: this is fine
Caption: so
Caption: what came next and this is my again this
Caption: is my memory of history and everyone's
Caption: memory of history is a little bit
Caption: you know
Caption: Along Came
Caption: um rest so essentially
Caption: um there was a guy named Jim Webber who
Caption: worked at a company called thoughtworks
Caption: I'm sure evidence of everyone here has
Caption: sort of thought Works yep so we're going
Caption: to Jim Webber
Caption: um The Story Goes he was working on some
Caption: horrible rescue project sitting in a
Caption: data center trying to fix Biz talk at
Caption: one in the morning and just where enough
Caption: of this is terrible so he and a couple
Caption: of colleagues started to just go we're
Caption: not going to put some in this talk we're
Caption: just going to build a service over here
Caption: in tomcat and just put an HTTP API on it
Caption: and and we can call that and just kind
Caption: of you know
Caption: um separate some of those functionality
Caption: out and end up writing a book on rest
Caption: called rest in practice I think really
Caption: good book on rest and sort of it was
Caption: around the time that rest sort of became
Caption: popular and and you know thought work
Caption: started to do a lot of stuff around
Caption: these HTTP Based Services that were
Caption: simple built on I think Jetty
Caption: um and and using rest and and hypertext
Caption: um around the time I first heard the
Caption: term microservices it was sort of it's
Caption: sort of emanating
Caption: um from a company called SoundCloud I'm
Caption: sure a lot of you heard of SoundCloud
Caption: needed audio streaming and downloading
Caption: stuff
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: SoundCloud had an application it was
Caption: um it was getting big they were getting
Caption: popular
Caption: and it was very monolithic very hard to
Caption: maintain wasn't scaling well so they
Caption: hired a bunch of people actually from
Caption: thoughtworks in Berlin
Caption: and one of the leaders there was a guy
Caption: named Phil calcotto
Caption: and so what they what Phil started to do
Caption: with this team was was breaking stuff
Caption: off so I had this this big monolithic
Caption: rails app and they'd break some stuff
Caption: off built a simple HTTP service over it
Caption: and um you know and a few other people
Caption: in that space were doing similar things
Caption: and eventually they became sort of known
Caption: as microservices
Caption: so
Caption: the historical sort of timeline here is
Caption: you can kind of go from sewer to bad
Caption: sewer to http to rest to microservices
Caption: and then a guy named Sam Newman who was
Caption: also a thoughtworks wrote a book on it
Caption: which I'm sure a lot of people have seen
Caption: and it kind of just exploded from there
Caption: but of course we ended up back here
Caption: where we had lots of services a couple
Caption: of applications but all the services
Caption: talking to each other a lot of people
Caption: did it again with a shared database and
Caption: got the modeling completely wrong
Caption: and we ended up back here this is fine
Caption: so who's worked on one of these in my in
Caption: microservice land yeah a few people
Caption: right
Caption: so that's the history so where does it
Caption: go wrong and this is you know I've spent
Caption: a lot of time digging out of this and
Caption: and thinking about it
Caption: and the first place that goes wrong
Caption: is people get way too caught up in the
Caption: tech
Caption: yeah and this is a
Caption: fairly common pattern in our industry
Caption: you've got a problem to solve
Caption: you start a project everyone's excited
Caption: you still don't really know what the
Caption: business requirements are because that's
Caption: someone else's job as a developer
Caption: and so we're like we're sitting here we
Caption: don't know what to do I know we'll build
Caption: our own framework and we'll build our
Caption: own orm and we'll build out whatever and
Caption: so
Caption: in in in more recent years people then
Caption: get really hung up on the infrastructure
Caption: it's like right we need to build a thing
Caption: it's like cool first we need to do is
Caption: get kubernetes and put Kafka and
Caption: postgres and kubernetes and just get way
Caption: hung up on the infrastructure before
Caption: shipping a loan of code
Caption: and essentially you start solving
Caption: problems that you don't have yet you
Caption: don't know you're going to have yet
Caption: um you know tools are great all of those
Caption: tools that I mentioned are fantastic
Caption: tools and fantastic infrastructure but
Caption: um if you
Caption: start layering on stuff before you've
Caption: even understand the problem you probably
Caption: need to stop
Caption: it's kind of agile one-on-one right like
Caption: we don't do big design up front a lot of
Caption: people do it like a map I saw one
Caption: recently there's some tool
Caption: it's like a graph like a graphing tool
Caption: for sort of object graphs and like a
Caption: team that had not actually shipped
Caption: the system and the object graph of
Caption: services was like I couldn't fit in on
Caption: my monitor and they'd never actually
Caption: shipped anything this has got way hung
Caption: up on stuff and just solving problems
Caption: that you know they didn't have yet
Caption: so sometimes when I'm feeling snarky
Caption: I'll say to people if you haven't
Caption: shipped one thing what makes you think
Caption: you can ship 20 tomorrow
Caption: and that makes me popular
Caption: yeah I've never had this conversation
Caption: like right we need to start this thing
Caption: it's like first thing we need to do is
Caption: choose a container orchestration
Caption: platforms like well you really don't you
Caption: actually have a bunch of stuff over here
Caption: your legacy system it's a bunch of
Caption: servers and you know there's a proof of
Caption: concept like let's see if we can ship a
Caption: small thing
Caption: and um you know so people just way hung
Caption: up on that
Caption: so
Caption: one of the the attributes I've seen of
Caption: microservices architecture that have
Caption: been very successful is they've evolved
Caption: from something that worked
Caption: apparently SoundCloud example that had a
Caption: rails app had traffic they might have
Caption: even been making money crazy
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: you know they started with something and
Caption: it was creaky and they sort of broke a
Caption: little about and started with something
Caption: that worked and typically those things
Caption: work quite well because you here's a
Caption: problem let's take a chunk of it off the
Caption: ones that start with a blank slate and
Caption: go cool we're going to need 30 Services
Caption: typically never ship
Caption: again because if people have not worked
Caption: with this stuff before they don't
Caption: actually know what challenges they're
Caption: going to hit
Caption: so yeah often good architecture will
Caption: evolve from good working software or
Caption: maybe it's not working well but you've
Caption: got something that works you understand
Caption: it and you evolve from there so often
Caption: the the yeah most of the successful
Caption: stories I've seen have started from
Caption: something that was already there
Caption: particularly with Legacy systems I've
Caption: seen a lot of
Caption: who's worked on a failed Legacy system
Caption: replacement
Caption: yeah right and generally they were like
Caption: here's this thing it's old it's clunky
Caption: we don't like it it's buggy it's hard to
Caption: maintain you're like cool what we're
Caption: going to do is we're going to start
Caption: again over here and this time we're
Caption: going to do it right
Caption: yeah
Caption: and you never get there right like you
Caption: never you never ship it so
Caption: whenever a new requirement comes in a
Caption: new requirements always come in they're
Caption: like well that's not ready it doesn't do
Caption: X Y and Z so we'll put it over here and
Caption: all of a sudden you're chasing the
Caption: target you'll never actually hit yes
Caption: Familia
Caption: yep um Legacy system Replacements that
Caption: work really well is you've got an
Caption: architecture that lets you sort of move
Caption: something across at a time and make them
Caption: talk and go we've got this new
Caption: requirement we'll put it over here and
Caption: we'll integrate it because software is
Caption: never done you know software is done
Caption: like a lawn is mode you can mow the lawn
Caption: you know the next day you're gonna need
Caption: to mow it again or the next week so the
Caption: idea that we're going to just replace a
Caption: system turn it on turn the old one off
Caption: and we're done you know it's just not
Caption: not a realistic one
Caption: so now I get to the click bait
Caption: other than all of that stuff
Caption: the one thing that you need to know for
Caption: successful microservices architecture
Caption: is software modeling
Caption: which you know gets thrown away modeling
Caption: is hard like software modeling is hard
Caption: this is why we have jobs because
Caption: modeling good software is a tricky thing
Caption: to do and it's hard to do in one
Caption: solution you know if you like file a new
Caption: project in your IDE of choice
Caption: and you go right we need to solve this
Caption: problem
Caption: um it's hard right like coming up with
Caption: the design and the modeling is a tricky
Caption: thing to do and it's hard in one project
Caption: if you start with 20 and you need to
Caption: refactor something you know all of a
Caption: sudden you've just you know multiplied
Caption: this problem
Caption: and so what people typically do is
Caption: spin out all their services 20 of them
Caption: um and then realize that they've not got
Caption: the modeling right and then you sort of
Caption: start routing around everything and
Caption: everything talks to everything else and
Caption: you know we're back to that kind of bad
Caption: sewer thing and then people bring in
Caption: more infrastructure to solve our
Caption: services are talking too much let's
Caption: bring in a service match or poly or
Caption: something like that
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah modeling
Caption: so a couple of common really like common
Caption: sort of code smells or architecture
Caption: smells that I see
Caption: um
Caption: my favorite one is when you've got a
Caption: service for an infrastructure function
Caption: who has worked on a data service or a
Caption: data manager no good
Caption: um
Caption: so you know if you've got a service that
Caption: are based around sort of infrastructure
Caption: things you're probably going to be
Caption: having a bit of a bad time
Caption: um but the other main one that goes
Caption: wrong is what gets called The Entity
Caption: service anti-pattern or a service per
Caption: aggregate route
Caption: do those names just go over everyone's
Caption: head around me
Caption: who's read this book
Caption: who's actually read it
Caption: who got to the end
Caption: yeah it is it's a it's an amazing book
Caption: it's one of the driest books you'll ever
Caption: read
Caption: um
Caption: and and one of the things about this
Caption: book is actually who does domain driven
Caption: design
Caption: a few people you're hesitant you like
Caption: and I'm gonna get called out in a second
Caption: so you've got some repositories
Caption: some services
Caption: yeah
Caption: do you have an on-site business Expert
Caption: that you talk to and develop a custom
Caption: vocabulary vocab you yeah okay cool
Caption: excellent
Caption: um you're the first one
Caption: so domain driven design is actually a
Caption: book around software modeling but nobody
Caption: gets to that bit because it's a chapter
Caption: 15.
Caption: people get through the first few
Caption: chapters around services and repository
Caption: pattern and blah blah blah blah and
Caption: naming your functions really long things
Caption: and then never get to the final chapters
Caption: and Eric Evans actually I saw him give a
Caption: talk about
Caption: um about this book and he went if I had
Caption: my time again I would just like change
Caption: the order of the chapters because nobody
Caption: actually gets to the to the meaty bit
Caption: so
Caption: you know if you're modeling software
Caption: you might have a customer an order in a
Caption: shopping cart and catalog and pricing
Caption: things like that when you're doing your
Caption: modeling and
Caption: that's called an entity or an aggregate
Caption: route in in domain driven design right
Caption: so often what we see is services that
Caption: look like this and you can go and look
Caption: like Microsoft best practice
Caption: microservices you get something that
Caption: looks a lot like this and all of a
Caption: sudden we've got a service for every
Caption: entity in our in our model yeah does
Caption: anyone remember JaVale Lowe
Caption: early no cool early so uh said and I
Caption: never thought this was a very outlandish
Caption: thing to say but JaVale Lowry said that
Caption: that in a good service oriented
Caption: architecture every class would be a
Caption: service
Caption: and everyone laughed this was a
Caption: ridiculous thing to say but we've kind
Caption: of ended up here
Caption: again this is my grumpy old man showing
Caption: um
Caption: so what happens is you know software
Caption: there's a couple of
Caption: principles of good software design
Caption: around
Caption: um like loose coupling and and cohesion
Caption: and
Caption: as a software to collaborate within its
Caption: design needs you know cohesion and if
Caption: we've split it too far apart then all of
Caption: a sudden you know
Caption: we're talking too much over you know
Caption: http
Caption: and you know then you have to deal with
Caption: distributed computing
Caption: a lot you know because software you know
Caption: is cohesive all these things talk to
Caption: each other and if all of a sudden you're
Caption: talking to each other over a network
Caption: boundary then you know again you've got
Caption: all sorts of problems
Caption: and so what I see is service is just are
Caption: way too chatty has anyone kind of worked
Caption: on a microservices architecture it's
Caption: just way too chatty
Caption: so then you bring in more infrastructure
Caption: you bring in you know istio and
Caption: um sidecar services and service meshes
Caption: and and things like that to solve the
Caption: fact that we've just split our design
Caption: way too early and our boundaries are
Caption: done um
Caption: way way too early
Caption: so some of the symptoms of that
Caption: when you see it is
Caption: um massive amounts of shared code
Caption: so then we go okay all of our services
Caption: need the same classes in there so okay
Caption: we need a mono repo or or Worse still we
Caption: have everything in one giant solution
Caption: and I've seen that like 20 micro
Caption: services in one Visual Studio solution
Caption: because they need so much shared code
Caption: and then you have back to the problem
Caption: that we had in you know the early 2000s
Caption: which is you need to deploy everything
Caption: exactly the same order
Caption: because you've got four services with
Caption: the same classes and if those classes
Caption: don't match
Caption: you got all sorts of Errors so then you
Caption: know everything has to be deployed at
Caption: exactly the same time so they're not
Caption: autonomous anymore
Caption: um when I was at octopus deploy one of
Caption: the things that we did at octopus and
Caption: they still do is pretty much everyone
Caption: does a rotation on customer support
Caption: which is if you've never done it it's an
Caption: amazing way to develop empathy for your
Caption: customer
Caption: and you can make design decisions and
Caption: then see the impact of that by figuring
Caption: out what's hard for people to do and
Caption: where they get it wrong it's amazingly
Caption: an amazing process for kind of building
Caption: empathy when you're within your team
Caption: the people would would write in or email
Caption: in right in
Caption: and they'd say octopus doesn't support
Caption: microservices I mean like what what do
Caption: you mean it's like we have all of our
Caption: services each one's its own project but
Caption: we need all the projects to be deployed
Caption: at exactly the same time
Caption: so what this gets snarkly cold is you
Caption: don't have microservices you have a
Caption: distributed monolith which is kind of
Caption: the worst of
Caption: the worst of all of those worlds
Caption: um and then again when you start adding
Caption: infrastructure to it
Caption: so
Caption: for those of you who got through 15
Caption: chapters of the domain-driven design
Caption: book
Caption: there's a concept called a bounded
Caption: context
Caption: and
Caption: again this is a book about modeling and
Caption: and you start speaking to experts within
Caption: the business
Caption: and you develop a shared vocabulary and
Caption: in chapter 15 of the domain driven
Caption: design book
Caption: Eric Evan says that if you start to
Caption: notice that different groups of people
Caption: in the business start using words
Caption: differently or talking about something
Caption: with a different phrase that's a bounded
Caption: context yeah
Caption: um and you find that you know if anyone
Caption: sort of worked in a big organization you
Caption: might say well this thing is an order
Caption: but an order to somebody else is a
Caption: completely different concept someone
Caption: felt felt that one yep
Caption: so the best example of this I've heard
Caption: um was from a guy named Dan North who
Caption: was also thoughtworks and and he had a
Caption: taught a bunch of years ago
Caption: that I'm going to steal shamelessly
Caption: where he talked about going on holiday
Caption: and he has this this concept of okay I'm
Caption: going on holiday
Caption: um
Caption: and your view of your holiday might be a
Caption: a postcard or or a you know a website or
Caption: a magazine article where you've got
Caption: Beach you know white sandy beach
Caption: cocktail umbrella you know snorkeling
Caption: whatever it is that's your I'm going on
Caption: holiday I'm really stressed I need to go
Caption: and sit on the beach okay that's your
Caption: view of a holiday
Caption: um but to get there you need to do a few
Caption: things you need to put in a leave
Caption: request okay it's in your HR department
Caption: um needs to think about your holiday now
Caption: your HR department's view of your
Caption: holiday is not like sandy beaches in a
Caption: cocktail with an umbrella in it
Caption: um your hr's view of your holiday is do
Caption: you have enough leave days
Caption: kind of thing how many hours have you
Caption: accrued you might also have to get that
Caption: signed up by your manager
Caption: your manager's view of your holiday
Caption: might be well actually we have this
Caption: project deadline we've got our Legacy
Caption: system replacement it's due to go live
Caption: next month no you can't go on holiday
Caption: um which is exactly why you need to go
Caption: on holiday
Caption: um
Caption: you might call a travel agent to you
Caption: know book you a flight and a hotel so
Caption: they're going to have a completely
Caption: different set of words and different
Caption: lens and different framing of your
Caption: holiday it's all the same thing
Caption: but everybody has a completely different
Caption: set of terminology and way of thinking
Caption: about and framing your holiday and and
Caption: that's about a context yeah
Caption: so
Caption: it's a bounded context around the people
Caption: involved in something and and the
Caption: interactions with it
Caption: Okay so
Caption: if you think about Building Services you
Caption: can start to use that framing around
Caption: what a service is so if you've got a
Caption: bounded context you know well we look at
Caption: this thing and it means this to us that
Caption: might be a really good place to start
Caption: with a service yeah
Caption: and then what you can do is model the
Caption: communication across the people in this
Caption: organization and
Caption: how they communicate that stuff and that
Caption: becomes then a really good shape of of
Caption: what your service looks like and what
Caption: that sort of bounded context looks like
Caption: so you know
Caption: um
Caption: if somebody says in your organization go
Caption: do this
Caption: that's a that's called a command or if
Caption: somebody else sits there and they wait
Caption: for it wait to be told about something
Caption: that's an event and we can start to
Caption: model then commands and events and
Caption: requests within an organization
Caption: so
Caption: to put an example on that
Caption: think about
Caption: a really bad restaurant
Caption: okay you imagine turning up to a
Caption: restaurant and you sit down with your
Caption: friends and
Caption: a waiter comes up with a menu board with
Caption: no prices on it
Caption: let's go here are the things
Caption: and you'd say
Caption: um
Caption: how much is the burger and they just run
Caption: away and come back and go that's you
Caption: know 12.
Caption: and you go
Caption: I'll have a burger thanks and they go
Caption: okay
Caption: I'll just check if we have them and they
Caption: run back into the kitchen come back and
Caption: go yes you can have a Bergen like cool
Caption: well I'd like the burger thanks
Caption: um and we'd also like the fish and like
Caption: hang on and they run back into the
Caption: kitchen a few minutes later come back
Caption: okay no we don't have fish
Caption: and so you're frustrating well can we
Caption: have some pizza now run back in and they
Caption: go through this process of like running
Caption: back in and checking if they have it for
Caption: all of the food and all of the drinks
Caption: for every single person at the table
Caption: and then you go okay got the order right
Caption: I would like that and they go cool that
Caption: will cost this
Caption: well we haven't eaten yet but you know
Caption: okay here's the card and they walk and
Caption: they stand in line behind all the other
Caption: staff in one line to get to the one f
Caption: plus machine payment gateways are hard
Caption: and eventually they get there
Caption: process your card and it's declined so
Caption: they come back and go that card was
Caption: declined Ah that's right I'm gonna put
Caption: money on that account so you transfer
Caption: some money over and they go and get back
Caption: in the line
Caption: and you're sitting there at this point
Caption: you're hungry you're grumpy
Caption: um because this order still hasn't gone
Caption: to the kitchen because you haven't paid
Caption: for it yet they come back and go yes
Caption: that was successful and then they go
Caption: into the kitchen to place your order and
Caption: they just disappear you don't see them
Caption: again
Caption: for a long time
Caption: and you realize that all the weight
Caption: staff are walking into the kitchen
Caption: and not coming out until they have the
Caption: food
Caption: yeah So eventually your waiter comes out
Caption: um
Caption: gives you food and you and you eat the
Caption: field but eat the meal at that point you
Caption: know you're having a bad time it's not
Caption: it's not a great dining experience one
Caption: star would not do again
Caption: um and this company is not going to last
Caption: too long because they're going to need
Caption: way too many staff they're going to go
Caption: through the stuff because everyone's
Caption: rude to them
Caption: um and it just it's not going to scale
Caption: right
Caption: has anyone been to this restaurant
Caption: sounds pretty bad
Caption: this is how we build systems this is how
Caption: a lot of people build software
Caption: um
Caption: because you know coming back to this
Caption: kind of
Caption: sort of canonical microservice
Caption: architecture that you see it looks like
Caption: this
Caption: and we've got all of these HTTP requests
Caption: now what's something about HTTP requests
Caption: the synchronous okay and so we build
Caption: this stuff and this is kind of how we
Caption: build this restaurant like I would like
Caption: to do this I will go check the pricing
Caption: service like literally every micro
Caption: service kind of beginning article has a
Caption: cart service and a pricing service
Caption: um and that's like the way to holding
Caption: the board and then going have to ask the
Caption: manager how much the burger is
Caption: um
Caption: and it's bad this is how we build
Caption: systems
Caption: so
Caption: let's think about a better restaurant
Caption: you walk in you sit down the staff hands
Caption: you out some menus the menus have prices
Caption: on the menus have specials on them
Caption: because somebody sat down when those
Caption: prices change created a menu and put it
Caption: on there you sit down and they go
Caption: actually look I just the kitchen just
Caption: told me we've just run out of fish so
Caption: that one's not in there you know okay
Caption: cool that's fine I'll order something
Caption: else
Caption: you sit there and you go here's the
Caption: order and the staff you know write the
Caption: food on one slip and the drinks on
Caption: another slip and they you know take one
Caption: slip to the kitchen another one to the
Caption: bar and your orders in all easy
Caption: and then after a few minutes
Caption: um
Caption: bell rings at the kitchen
Caption: okay and some staff go over to see what
Caption: the Bell was for it's like okay table
Caption: ten food's ready and they bring
Caption: to your table and you sit down and eat
Caption: it
Caption: and
Caption: when it's time to go you go up and you
Caption: pay like to pay for table 10. again you
Caption: might still have the f plus problem but
Caption: it's easy you know just just kind of
Caption: solve it
Caption: and meanwhile you've got a restaurant
Caption: manager who's sitting there kind of
Caption: overseeing like this table got their
Caption: food on time is anyone waiting too long
Caption: is everything kind of working as it is
Caption: right
Caption: that's a better restaurant because
Caption: you've got
Caption: um
Caption: it's for your staff and they're getting
Caption: more done
Caption: because they're not relying on waiting
Caption: for answers all the time they take your
Caption: order into the kitchen they say make
Caption: this yep
Caption: and when it's ready someone rings a bell
Caption: and they come and get it
Caption: one's a command
Caption: another one's an event yeah
Caption: and so
Caption: the way these like it's the same
Caption: activities they're still ordering food
Caption: and they're still cooking food and the
Caption: silvering is still paying but it's the
Caption: way those activities are are grouped and
Caption: who's in charge of it and how the
Caption: communication happens is better modeling
Caption: yeah does anyone go and watch businesses
Caption: and just like think about the systems
Caption: you know like massively into systems
Caption: thinking and you look at that and go if
Caption: that person did that job everything
Caption: would go better yeah it's great great
Caption: people watching
Caption: I can't help myself
Caption: um and and it's modeling right
Caption: um and so in this restaurant the staff
Caption: know when something's run out they've
Caption: got the prices of stuff the kitchen
Caption: knows when to make something you don't
Caption: have
Caption: a waiter standing in this kitchen going
Caption: is it ready yet is it ready yet is it
Caption: ready yet is it ready yet is it ready
Caption: yet you know someone rings a bell okay
Caption: good modeling and this is a good
Caption: restaurant you leave from this good
Caption: experience five-star would eat again
Caption: so
Caption: what can we take from this
Caption: chains of requests do not scale well
Caption: yeah then I worked in a company where to
Caption: get anything done you have to ask your
Caption: manager and they ask their manager and
Caption: then they asked kind of a sideways and
Caption: it goes down and you're sitting there
Caption: and you're like couldn't I have just
Caption: gone and talked to them
Caption: it doesn't scale
Caption: um it's not a fun place to work the
Caption: chains of requests do not scale it's not
Caption: a way to get things done
Caption: people that have the information to do
Caption: their job are a lot more effective at it
Caption: um again these are kind of Fairly
Caption: commonly known things
Caption: um
Caption: but software boundaries that follow
Caption: these same principles tend to work
Caption: better and a lot of it is around
Caption: synchronicity so you know synchronous
Caption: things where you're waiting for an
Caption: answer don't scale and don't kind of
Caption: work as well as things that are
Caption: asynchronous
Caption: again
Caption: ring the bell the food's ready
Caption: so
Caption: applying this to Services if a service
Caption: knows enough to do its job
Caption: then it's going to scale better it's
Caption: going to work better so I have a I have
Caption: a cute name for this which is
Caption: human-shaped microservices
Caption: trademark
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um so you know when I look at it when I
Caption: look at a a software system and kind of
Caption: try to to bring it down to well if
Caption: people were doing it
Caption: who would the people be what would they
Caption: be in charge of
Caption: um how would they do that thing and how
Caption: would they communicate it so what would
Caption: people do if we were building this
Caption: system out of people
Caption: and
Caption: again synchronous chains of people
Caption: asking a question going what's the
Caption: answer what's the answer what's the
Caption: answer is not a good it's not you know
Caption: an effective business to to be in so you
Caption: look at well if you're going to group
Caption: this and have people doing those jobs
Caption: um
Caption: how would you organize that company to
Caption: be effective
Caption: and then build the systems the same way
Caption: so a really good technique for this
Caption: something called event storming has
Caption: anyone seen events stormy what kind of a
Caption: modeling technique where you get Post-it
Caption: notes on a board and and you say well
Caption: if we're doing this you know I would
Caption: tell the kitchen to make these things
Caption: okay that's a command and then the
Caption: kitchen would say this order is ready
Caption: that's an event and you kind of with
Caption: different colored sticky notes
Caption: stick them all on a board with these are
Caption: the commands and these are the events
Caption: and then figure out what talks to what
Caption: and why and you end up with a really
Caption: good mapping of the way an organization
Caption: should work
Caption: and then build the software around that
Caption: so again
Caption: um
Caption: commands and events work really well
Caption: here
Caption: I'm going to quickly talk about kind of
Caption: the tech of that because often like
Caption: people sort of tend to think about
Caption: microservices as you know just rest but
Caption: I actually really like messaging for a
Caption: lot of this stuff
Caption: because it Maps really quite well
Caption: so HTTP is a synchronous
Caption: transport you know that's about
Caption: requesting a document and getting
Caption: something back and what we've learned is
Caption: synchronous calls will reduce your
Caption: reliability
Caption: um and they reduce your ability to scale
Caption: and you have to deploy stuff at exactly
Caption: the right time because it's not
Caption: something there you know it gets hard
Caption: um
Caption: so you can still use HTTP to model
Caption: commands and events if you want but it
Caption: ends up being a bunch more work you
Caption: might have a table of events and then
Caption: you know all the other services have to
Caption: kind of poll that table and keep a
Caption: cursor and it's extra database stuff so
Caption: messaging kind of works really really
Caption: well for this
Caption: um
Caption: um you know for this for this style of
Caption: thing because you can you can put a
Caption: command on a queue
Caption: sorry
Caption: um
Caption: and yeah you can have Pub sub and and
Caption: messaging systems work really really
Caption: well for microservices
Caption: rest is still a great API service
Caption: particularly on the web like the web is
Caption: built around HTTP we've got cdns we've
Caption: got proxies you know like it's a it's a
Caption: really good protocol and there's lots of
Caption: semantics built into it
Caption: um into HTTP and then you sort of apply
Caption: a rest Style on top of that that's a
Caption: whole other discussion
Caption: um
Caption: let me get a hypertext is a good thing
Caption: like a lot of the web is built on that
Caption: and the scales really really well
Caption: so I have a pattern that I've had a lot
Caption: of success with that again as a joke one
Caption: day I call it mullet micro services
Caption: um because it's got rest on the front
Caption: and messaging in the back
Caption: and people seem to like that so I'm I'm
Caption: sticking with it but this is the part
Caption: I've had a lot of success with even in
Caption: sort of replacing Legacy systems where
Caption: you can build Services behind a load
Caption: balancer yeah
Caption: but their back plane the way they
Caption: communicate to each other is through
Caption: messages from a message broker or you
Caption: know something like that
Caption: and I'm running out of time quickly some
Caption: conclusions
Caption: um
Caption: from all of this is learn from history
Caption: like if you want to set out to to use a
Caption: new technique or a new tool or a piece
Caption: of infrastructure or a pattern or you
Caption: know whatever it is understand that idea
Caption: and what led to it like what problem
Caption: was being solved when somebody created
Caption: this thing what caused that problem that
Caption: they were going to solve
Caption: what caused that you know understand the
Caption: history of of in context of how we got
Caption: there
Caption: and doing that will just make you a
Caption: better technologist like we're going to
Caption: use this thing and it was designed to
Caption: solve this problem we have that problem
Caption: it's a good fit if it's we want to do
Caption: that because it's on hacking news and
Caption: it's really cool you're going to be a
Caption: less effective technologist
Caption: um another takeaway is microservices and
Caption: so I kind of have the same roots and the
Caption: same problems they're about if you go
Caption: back and read sort of the the early
Caption: stuff around so it's about services that
Caption: are Loosely coupled and autonomously
Caption: manage a business process and
Caption: microservices are kind of the same but a
Caption: bit smaller but essentially the
Caption: principles are there
Caption: um
Caption: and you know if we sort of don't like
Caption: autonomously manage that business
Caption: process they get super chatty
Caption: in modeling look at the people business
Caption: processes how would people do that model
Caption: your software after that and then the
Caption: main one is never forget that actually
Caption: delivering value is the goal
Caption: um that's what we're here for that's the
Caption: smart bit like your job isn't well I you
Caption: know bring containers to an organization
Caption: your job is about you know delivering
Caption: value where that's selling something to
Caption: customers or solving the internal
Caption: Problem whatever it is that's the goal
Caption: um and we get way too caught up in that
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah with that I'm going to do a a
Caption: quick plug
Caption: um which is I'm teaching this stuff
Caption: um and if anyone wants to come and talk
Caption: to me about that I would love to have
Caption: that chat
Caption: um essentially I've seen this enough
Caption: times that I'm like what can I do about
Caption: this so I actually want to teach it you
Caption: know teach this stuff and get Hands-On
Caption: but I don't want to make it too much of
Caption: a plug with that we're getting low on
Caption: time
Caption: any questions and I'm happy to I'm happy
Caption: for you too I cost me all day and and
Caption: chat about this stuff but any questions
Caption: in the room
Caption: what
Caption: thanks for that that was great mate
Caption: um I work in a medium-sized organization
Caption: that was that's now integrating with a
Caption: very large organization
Caption: um what are the kind of
Caption: I guess cultural preconditions for
Caption: microservices and especially in an
Caption: organization that's already on the
Caption: journey but but yeah yeah that's a
Caption: that's a tricky one and I like honestly
Caption: I've not seen a one-size-fits all to
Caption: that
Caption: um the biggest problem seems to be in
Caption: those those Journeys and those
Caption: organizations is that
Caption: it's very hard to get anything started
Caption: because they're so risk adverse that no
Caption: one ever wants to fail so it's you know
Caption: and I've I've seen this in a big
Caption: organization where it's like we want to
Caption: do this thing very simple and they're
Caption: like you can't do that because we are
Caption: still figuring out what our container
Caption: strategy is or what our messaging
Caption: strategy is or and then you've got you
Caption: know a team of Enterprise Architects
Caption: that will take 12 months to make a
Caption: ruling on something before you can touch
Caption: it it's all very like oh
Caption: um and that's super hard
Caption: um if you're in that organization and
Caption: you can ship
Caption: then
Caption: um
Caption: yeah just do small things quickly and
Caption: again you know in in sort of technical
Caption: stuff HTTP is great like you don't want
Caption: to expose like if you've got you know
Caption: active mq or like a message broker back
Caption: there you probably don't want to expose
Caption: that because you want to change your
Caption: semantics so if you go well this is our
Caption: boundary is an API that people can
Caption: request and treat it like a third party
Caption: um yeah we'd love to hear more about it
Caption: later it's a yeah it's a tricky one
Caption: sorry everyone um Damien's been called
Caption: to the speaker photo now okay yeah we're
Caption: going to have to gotta go get my photo
Caption: took I'm sure though you can yes I'll be
Caption: right down later yeah
Caption: all right
Caption: yeah also if you don't want to come talk
Caption: to me Damien M on Twitter if you'd like
Caption: to tweet at me happy to do it um thank
Caption: you everyone so much